hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is your first look at the samsung galaxy
s6 now samsung has announced two new
phones today so the galaxy s6 and the
galaxy s6 edge and i have videos about
both up right now so definitely be sure
to check out that edge video as well
it'll be the first link below that like
button but this galaxy s6 is definitely
the more traditional looking of the two
new phones so this is the totally
reimagined samsung flagship supposedly
rebuilt from the ground up in its design
but if you ask me it has a lot of
elements that remind me of devices i've
used in the past but yeah so the leaks
were right you can see it looks like
another samsung phone from the front and
then it has chamfered metal sides to
grip real metal this time not plastic
that's painted to look like metal and
the button placement is all on point it
kind of feels like a mini note 4 in the
hand except for the back which switches
over to this very shimmery very glossy
very slippery glass back it's gorilla
glass 4 on the back and you don't
actually have to hold that glass though
since the glass curves on the edges
right to the metal so your hand is
basically just holding the metal all the
time so at least it has that going for
it it is slightly thinner than the
galaxy s5 it's just 6.8 millimeters thin
and it's also a bit narrower from left
to right thanks to the super thin bezels
on the sides kind of like the lg g3 so
that is one thing i really like it's a
5.1 inch display but it manages to fit
into a pretty compact usable sized body
even with the home button and the chin
and everything
and speaking of that display
it is gorgeous so it's a 5.1 inch quad
hd amoled display that gives it a pixel
density of
577 pixels per inch it basically looks
like a piece of paper when looking at
sharp text or images or video or
anything really it's really impressive
to look at plus it gets super bright up
to 600 candelas per meter squared that's
extremely bright for an oled display or
any smartphone display really and yeah
it's absolutely beautiful colors are
super saturated it will likely be the
best display on any smartphone when this
phone is released so that's samsung at
its best right there only thing that
remains to be seen is how long the
battery will last so obviously the
galaxy s5 had a 1080p display so i'll
have to see how long this galaxy s6 with
its 2550 milliamp hour battery can last
when you put through his paces in real
world use i'll definitely be testing
that a lot in the review now another
thing samsung has always done really
well is the camera and the galaxy s6 is
no exception to that rule it's rocking a
new 16 megapixel sensor but with all new
optics so an f 1.9 maximum aperture
which is super fast and i'm glad that
that's improving and so that combined
with optical image stabilization should
make some awesome images and video and
should be even better in low light too
there's also a shortcut to it just by
double tapping the home button from
anywhere so it's kind of like that
motorola double twist and it's actually
pretty fast so if some action unfolds in
front of you you don't have to think
twice or anything just double tap the
home button and you can take a photo in
probably a matter of under a second it's
also capable of 4k video again and yes i
know the camera protrudes a little bit
on the back and people have been talking
about that a lot but at least it's right
in the middle so it doesn't really
affect a lot it doesn't affect typing
when sitting on a table i tried that so
it's not really as much of a big deal as
some people have made it out to be also
you get a very wide angle front facing
camera too which also has an f 1.9
aperture plus some neat selfie tricks so
you can use your finger to tap the ir
sensor on the back of the phone to take
a photo since it's sort of a natural
place for your finger to rest so it
reminded me overall this phone a little
bit of the nexus 4 with that glossy
glass back which by the way is a serious
fingerprint magnet and it also reminded
me a little bit of the iphone 6 of
course with the bottom of the phone the
rounded metal the speaker grills and
also with the improved fingerprint
reader in a good way because it's a lot
faster and finally only requires a touch
instead of a swipe to unlock and get
into things it's definitely on top of
the spec game though with an octa-core
64-bit chip
three gigabytes of ram it's not ip67
certified anymore so no water resistance
and no expandable storage or removable
back but it added qi wireless charging
support and an infrared blaster on the
top and fast charging for 50 charge in
30 minutes with the supported charger
now samsung promised me something when
they told me about this phone they told
me they cut down on the xs software by
40
and i don't know how you measure that
but we all know by now that touchwiz is
infamous by how heavy it is how slow it
can make phones feel and also how ugly
it is now unfortunately it's still not
pretty it's it's running on top of
android 5.0 lollipop so there are you
know little flatter elements here and
there you have some material design once
in a while but you still have a swipe
over to samsung's my magazine you still
have all of samsung's ugly stock icons
and samsung's wallpapers and still have
some pre-loaded apps like a few
microsoft ones and samsung's milk music
so it's not totally gone but at least it
feels fast i was actually genuinely
impressed just scrolling around through
home pages and opening and closing apps
and flying through multitasking at how
smooth and quick the software glided
through everything animations didn't
stutter there wasn't really any lag
either so i can't say that about any
other quad hd phone even my nexus so
this is definitely the smoothest quad hd
phone out there which is promising i
still would have liked to see more cut
out of touchwiz or at least some
redesign of the icons or something like
that but overall the software experience
is definitely an improvement so overall
it's looking like the initial gut
reaction a lot of people have to this
phone is the design and that makes sense
people want to see a big visual change
on the outside and i gotta say this is
not the prettiest phone samsung has ever
made but i can tell you it's two
different things to look at the phone
versus actually holding this phone in
your hand it's actually one of the best
feeling phones samsung has made in a
while thanks to the new materials and
the tighter bezels and of course that
gorgeous display doesn't hurt either so
there you have it it's the most tame
version of samsung's two new flagships
announced today definitely let me know
what you guys want to see in the full
review when that goes live thank you for
watching this first impressions and i'll
talk to you guys in the next one
peace